hallo leute heute drehen wir wieder ein
video für unsere reihe über die
wichtigsten deutschen werben für euch
vielleicht habt ihr ja unser video über
das werk stellen gesehen ansonsten
schaut man hier oben
ich habe damals angekündigt dass wir
auch noch ein video über den unterschied
zwischen den verben stellen und legen
drehen werden
und das machen wir heute los geht's
zunächst einmal stelle ich euch die
beiden präsens kommunikation vor für das
werk stellen
ich stelle du stellst er sie es stellt
wir stellen hier stellt sie stellen und
für das werk legen
ich lege du legst er sie es legt wir
legen ihr legt sie legen wir wissen dass
viele deutsch lernschwierigkeiten haben
die beiden werben stellen und legen zu
unterscheiden weil es sich dabei um die
gleiche bewegung handelt nämlich einen
gegenstand auf einen untergrund bewegen
der feine unterschied ist allerdings wie
sich der gegenstand im endeffekt
physikalisch auf dem untergrund befindet
wenn man etwas legt dann impliziert man
damit dass der gegenstand am ende auf
der seite liegt also auf der größeren
fläche liegt
wenn man etwas stellt steht der
gegenstand also wenn man etwas legt
liegt der gegenstand diese kombination
der verben stellen und stehen und legen
und liegen könnt ihr euch gut merken mit
liegt auf dem sofa
[Musik]
mit steht auf dem sofa nur wer hat ihnen
auf das sofa gelegt oder gestellt ich
glaube das hat er selbst gemacht
ein weiteres gutes beispiel ist die
banane
ich lege die banane auf das regal
ich kann die banane allerdings nicht
stellen da die kleineren flächen also
die beiden enden viel zu klein sind um
sie darauf abzustellen beziehungsweise
meistens isst eine banane auch krumm
also sie kann nicht stehen sie liegt im
endeffekt ein gegenstand kann also immer
gelegt werden
aber nicht immer gestellt werden ich
lege die banane auf das regal die banane
liegt auf dem regal
übrigens wenn ihr noch mehr deutsche wm
lernen wollt dann schaut euch doch mal
den vokabeltrainer unserer apps i länger
da findet ihr noch mehr viele
komplizierte deutsche werben schaut mal
rein ihr fragt euch sicherlich warum hat
sie denn neben einer akkusativ und
einmal dativ benutzt
ich lege die banane auf das regal die
banane liegt auf dem regal wenn man die
position oder den ort wo sich der
gegenstand befindet schreiben will
nutzt man den dati die banane liegt auf
dem regal
die banane liegt auf dem tisch wir haben
auch schon mal ein video darüber gedreht
schaut mal hier so lass uns noch mal ein
paar beispiele zum unterschied zwischen
stellen und legen anschauen
ihr fragt euch jetzt vielleicht warum
nutzt man nicht einfach immer legen wenn
man doch alle gegenstände legen kann
das macht aber nicht immer sinn
schauen wir uns zum beispiel mal diese
öllampe an ein bisschen staubig und auch
noch nicht ganz funktionstüchtig aber
ihr wisst vielleicht wie diese
funktionieren würden wir diese öllampe
jetzt läge so kritsch dann würde die
nicht funktionieren der sinn ist dass
man sie anzünden kann also wissen wir
diese öllampe obwohl wir sie legen
können stellen denn wenn sie steht kann
sie auch brennen
schauen wir uns noch diese flasche
geöffnet es mir an die kann man
natürlich nicht legen
nein mit ja da war mir klar dass er das
jetzt versucht macht er jetzt ja ja das
ist eine möglichkeit aber also man
stellt sie natürlich hin aber wo man sie
zb legen könnte wäre im supermarkt auf
dem band an der kasse
dann fällt die flasche nicht so leicht
auf
ich lege das spiel auf das regal
ich lege das buch auf das regal oder ich
stelle das buch in das regal
ich stelle die pfeffermühle
ich lege den hundeknochen ich stelle das
glas ich stelle den kapitän auf das
regal
natürlich gibt es auch für das werk
legen einige kombination mit präfix
verlegen vorlegen anlegen auflegen
unterlegen sher legen
es gibt so einige für das werk stellen
haben wir bereits ein video darüber
gedreht stellen mit pre fixen und das
machen wir bald auch noch mal für das
werk legen
das war unser video über die verben
stellen und legen habt ihr den
unterschied verstanden dann schreibt uns
doch mal ein beispiel dass sie uns in
die kommentare
wenn ihr jetzt noch mehr deutsche werden
lernen wollt dann probiert doch mal demo
kabel trainer unserer app sie länger aus
dort findet ihr die 6.000 wichtigsten
deutschen vokabeln mit beispiel setzen
und aussprache trainings fußball
mit liegt auf dem sofa dann fällt uns
das nicht so leicht auf
[Musik]
deswegen da was geht